[MUSIC PLAYING]
HOCKFIELD: It's great to see
you all here this afternoon.
For those of you
who don't know, I'm
Susan Hockfield, the
president of MIT.
And I'd like to welcome
you all to this incredibly
special event.
We are enormously grateful
to our alumnus Mr. Mohammed
Jameel for making it possible
for Dr. Muhammad Yunus
to visit MIT today.
He's been visiting
with the Poverty Action
Lab and the Department
of Economics.
And he's giving us this
wonderful presentation
on ending global poverty.
It's a great honor to have
Dr. Yunus on our campus.
Dr. Yunus is internationally
recognized for his work
in alleviating power poverty
and empowering poor women.
He's the founder of
the Grameen Bank,
a microcredit
institution, created
to provide the poor with
tiny amounts of working
capital for self-employment.
Since its launch three decades
ago as an action research
project, the bank has
made more than $5 billion
in collateral-free loans
to 5 million borrowers
in Bangladesh.
96% of the borrowers are women.
And the bank now lends
half a billion a year
to the poorest of the poor,
while maintaining a repayment
rate of 99%.
This innovative approach
to alleviating poverty
has inspired a global
microcredit movement
that reaches out to millions
of poor women on all five
continents.
Through this work,
Dr. Yunus may well
be the most influential
economist in the world.
Dr. Yunus has kindly indicated
that he will take questions
after his remarks.
And Dean Philip Khoury from
the School of Humanities, Arts,
and Social Sciences
will moderate
that portion of this
afternoon's presentation.
But for now, I
would ask you please
to join me in welcoming
Dr. Muhammad Yunus to MIT.
[INAUDIBLE]
[APPLAUSE]
YUNUS: Thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
It's a great honor to be here.
And thank you, Susan,
for introducing me.
And I'm so happy to talk
about the kind of work I do.
It will be very brief.
I hope I had more
time to elaborate.
People tell me, what's so great
about giving such a tiny loan
to poor people?
So I don't know how to
answer that question-- what's
so great about giving so
tiny loans to poor people?
So one idea that came to my
mind, maybe, I thought people
understand it better if
I put it this way that
imagine a situation
where suddenly,
all the banks in the
world got closed,
shut down, non-functional.
What will happen to
people around the world?
And then thinking
about it, I thought
this would be a good
Hollywood story.
You can build a
good film out of it.
It would be a horror movie,
like Godzilla or something.
About 2/3 of the world
population situation
is like that.
For them, financial
institutions do not exist.
But the horror that it should
have created in their life,
neither they see it
nor we, the people who
have banks around us, see it.
Because we took it as
a part of our life.
But that's what it is for
2/3 of the world population.
Doors of the
financial institutions
have closed to them.
So their life has to be
designed another way.
And when you say other way,
it's not a very pleasant way.
Because we created a world
which goes around with money.
You need money at
every step of the way.
If you don't have
the first dollar,
you can't catch
the next dollars.
You need $1 to catch $1.
And nobody gives
them the first dollar
to catch the next dollar.
And that's the situation,
what you describe as poverty.
It's not their fault
that they are poor.
We simply refuse
them the privilege
of getting out of poverty.
So when we talk about
eliminating poverty
in the world, we are not
thinking about some people who
don't know what to do in their
life, illiterate, ignorant,
and that's why they are poor.
That's not the way it is.
They're as good human
being as anybody else.
As enterprising as anybody else.
As smart as anybody else.
But simply, they are denied
of certain basic amenities
to use their talent,
use their creativity,
use their ingenuity to
move out of poverty.
So back in the '70s
when I was teaching
in one of the universities
in Bangladesh,
Bangladesh was going
through a terrible famine.
Famine is a horrible situation
where people die of hunger,
just not being able to eat.
There's not food.
So it's not a very pleasant
thing in a situation like that,
teaching elegant
theories of economics.
Writing down all your
equations and so on.
And telling students
how to overcome
all the economic difficulties,
empowered by the theories
that we have in our textbooks.
That empowerment doesn't get
translated into real world
just outside the
classroom, where
people are going through
this experience of famine.
So that trip took me out of the
classroom and trying to see,
is there something
that can be done?
And out of those
tiny little things,
one thing that I
confronted [? or ?] I
noticed in everyday
way in that how people
suffered for tiny little money.
And then, I took
a student of mine,
went around in the village
to list people who had
to borrow from the moneylender.
And when our list
was completed, there
were 42 names on that
list who took money
from the moneylenders.
And the total amount for the
whole 42 of them was $27.
So again, imagine
professor teaching
in the classroom about
the five-year development
plan for the country.
All the millions of dollars
and billions of dollars
you need to invest to overcome
the poverty in the country.
Has no idea that few meters
from that classroom, people
are not waiting for those
millions and billions.
Their life is going through
a miserable condition
because of few
pennies, less than $1.
So my first response was to
give $27 from my own pocket,
and tell them, please return
the money to the moneylenders.
And work whatever you want
to work with this money,
and be free.
And that sense of liberation
that came to them hooked me on.
I asked myself that if you can
make so many people so happy,
such a small amount of money,
shouldn't you do more of it?
So I was thinking
how to do more of it.
I could give more
money from my pocket,
but I thought that only
a solution, ultimately.
I was thinking more
something which
will be generating a system.
So I thought I
should link them up
with the bank which is
located in the campus.
Which I tried.
When I proposed to
the bank manager,
he literally fell from the sky.
He couldn't believe
that I'm saying
that he has to lend to these
people, this tiny amount.
He argued, very forcibly, that
the bank cannot lend money
to the poor people.
Poor people are not bankable.
Poor people are
not creditworthy.
He made all kinds of arguments,
which didn't make sense to me.
So I made out my arguments.
It's a no-go
situation, either side.
So anyway, the long story
continued for several months,
meeting all the bank
officials, trying to persuade
to take loans for the people.
Nobody would agree.
Ultimately, it was solved by
offering myself as a guarantor.
I said I'll sign
all your papers,
since your rules require it.
And you cannot accept them
because they don't have
the collateral.
And the banking system is
built around the collateral.
So the only way I can do it is
to offer myself as a guarantor.
That still took another
couple of months
of correspondence, and
discussions, and persuasions.
And finally, it was resolved.
And I started giving loans
to the people in the village.
The bank manager said you can
say goodbye to your money.
This is not going to come back.
I said, I'll take a chance.
I took my chance.
And along with it, I tried
to make some simple rules
to encourage them to pay back.
And it worked.
I got very excited that
it worked because the bank
manager said it won't work.
When I came to the bank
manager to give the good news
that everything is complete,
all the money came back,
he remained totally unimpressed.
He said maybe you did it a
few people in one village.
A professor can do all kinds
of miracles in one village.
We don't take it seriously.
So I said, what should I do?
He said you should do
it in two villages.
I said, OK, I'll do
I did it in two villages.
It worked beautifully.
But he remains as
unimpressed as he was.
So this is the story.
I go on doing it, and he
raises the number of villages.
And after I have done it several
times, then it dawned on me--
if I do it for the whole world,
he will not change his mind.
Because his mind is made.
Banking cannot be
done with poor people.
And I cannot undo that mind.
I said if now he says poor
people are not creditworthy,
they are not bankable,
I will scream.
I'll scream at the
top of my voice.
Said that's a lie,
that's not true.
Because I have done
it, I've seen it.
I said the real question is not
whether people are creditworthy
or not.
The real question is what
the banks are peopleworthy.
And they are not.
So I thought maybe
I should now create
a bank, which is different
from the banks that I know.
And I made a proposal
to the central bank,
that please allow me to
set up this bank which
will work for the poor people.
Central bank says we never
heard of that kind of bank.
It doesn't exist.
You better go to the government.
So I went to the government,
again, a long story.
Finally, we persuaded the
[INAUDIBLE] ultimately,
and we became a bank in 1983.
We were so delighted
that finally we
got ourselves a bank
for the poor people.
So what is the difference
between the bank
for the poor people
and banks that we know,
the conventional banks?
The basic difference is
the conventional banks
are built around the principle
that the more you have,
the more you can get.
Which meant if you have little
or nothing, you get nothing.
And that's why 2/3 of the world
population don't get anything.
So we reversed that principle
in designing our bank.
Our principle is
the less you have,
the higher priority you get.
If you have nothing, you
get the highest priority.
And we think that's what
the banking should be.
After all, people who
don't have anything,
they should be the ones who
should be getting something
to get it started.
And then people say it
may work in Bangladesh,
but it will never
work anywhere else.
Bangladesh is a funny country.
All kinds of funny
things happen there.
So maybe this is
another funny thing.
Well, luckily, many became
interested in our experience.
They want to do it
in their countries.
And gradually, it came out
in Malaysia, in Philippines,
in Indonesia.
We are very happy that it's
working in other countries.
Today, after all these
years, Grameen Bank
works all over Bangladesh.
We have over 5 million
borrowers right now, 96% women.
We lend out over a half a
billion a year in tiny loans,
averaging about $120 right now.
The money that we lend out
comes from the deposits.
It's not a bank.
Some people, there's donors
are giving the money,
and they're distributing it.
No, it's not like that.
It's just like a bank
is supposed to be--
taking deposits
and lending money.
That's what we do.
On top of it, what we have
done, unlike the banks that
were familiar with--
the conventional banks--
we focus on women.
96% of our borrowers are women.
No collateral needed.
No legal instruments are needed.
So there is no legal
instrument between the lender
and the borrower.
You don't have to sign,
and notarize, and stamp,
and all kinds of legal papers.
We don't have any legal papers.
How does it work?
You five half a billion
dollars and no papers?
And bankers tell
me, can you sleep?
I said I have very
peaceful sleep.
I have no problem.
Said without papers,
you gave all this money?
What if it doesn't come back?
I said I don't worry about it
because ever since we created,
money always comes back.
And it still does, 99%.
And the 1% is not money lost.
It's simply not paid within
the time limit, that's all.
It gets paid back, too,
after the time limit.
So it's a very happy situation.
We have savings, people
put money into the bank.
Right from the beginning,
we concentrated
on the children of the
families of Grameen Bank.
These are poor families.
They don't have any education,
illiterate families.
So we wanted to make sure our
children of Grameen families
are going to school.
And very soon, we
succeeded in doing that.
100% of the children of
Grameen families are in school.
Today, many of them are
in higher education,
going to colleges and
universities, medical schools,
engineering schools.
And Grameen Bank provides
them the student loans
so that they don't have to
worry about money for financing
their education.
There's kind of a
discussion of criticism
that microcredit
is a great idea,
and it's wonderful
for the poor people.
But it works only
for the top layer
of the poor people who have some
entrepreneurship, some skill.
It doesn't work for
the middle level
of the poor people, bottom
level of the poor people.
They need charity.
They need handouts.
Because they don't have
[INAUDIBLE] ability.
They don't have any skill.
We scream, that's not true.
Because in Bangladesh,
when we begin,
our loans are less than
$1, $27 to 42 people,
that's our starting point.
So these are not the top
layer the poor people
who receive this money.
And then we
concentrated on women.
These are not the Harvard
case studies or MIT case
studies of entrepreneurship.
The women coming and
pleading with us, please
don't give me the money, I
don't know anything about money.
Imagine that.
You go to the bank,
bank said well
you justify why we
should give you a bank.
Here we are going to the
people to give money,
they said, please
don't give us money.
So that's the kind
of bank we done.
And they became
so desperate, they
were arguing that please
give it to my husband.
He understands money.
I don't understand money.
Some said I never
touched money in my life.
So now you tell me, the
entrepreneurship skill
and so on, we went there
deliberately addressing them,
and brought them in.
But still people
go around saying,
well, is it a great
idea, but it doesn't work
for the middle and the lower.
So recently what we
have done is we have
got fed up with this argument.
We said, only way we can
stop this argument by kind
of dramatizing the whole thing.
We said, let's give
loans to the beggars.
You can't be poorer
than beggars.
That's the last stage.
Because one doesn't
have anything else,
so she goes on the street,
beg from people for finding
some food to survive.
So my colleagues ask,
what do we do with them?
We said, OK, let's
go and talk to them.
One thing we should
do, find out when she
became a beggar, at what point.
Because this is a very important
point, making a transition
from a normal human life to
the position of a beggar.
It's not easy.
So that we understand
her better.
And after we have
learned all this,
and then we sympathize
and say, OK,
as you go from house
to house begging,
would you like to carry
some merchandise with you,
some candies, some cookies,
some toys for the kids,
and give people option?
Well, they will give you some
food or buy something from you.
If you're selling
thing picks up,
you think you are
making enough, you
think whether you should switch
to selling rather than begging.
It's up to you.
And they started
liking this idea.
And in the beginning, we
thought we may have 3,000, 4,000
beggars in the program.
Soon, we came up with 50,000
And excitement of
turning themselves
into business
person, you wouldn't
believe what it means to them.
And we tell them, look,
Grameen Bank rules
do not apply for you.
So don't worry
about all our rules.
Forget it.
Only thing, this is a loan.
You'll have to pay
back as you can.
No interest-- it's
interest-free loan.
So don't worry about money
growing into big money.
So take it.
And never pay us with
your begging income.
That's not our money.
This is your money.
All we want, if you make
money by selling things,
then you can pay us back.
If you pay back the loan, you'll
be ready for another loan.
People understood
it very clearly.
A typical loan
for beggars is $9.
Imagine, with $9, people
thinking about a business idea
and how to bring herself
out of the begging.
Out of this-- now that
it's ongoing program,
we have about 1,000 beggars who
are no longer beggars anymore.
They are business people.
We said our success would be
if we can see, within a year,
within six months, 3,000,
5,000 have come out of begging.
I said, this is--
and what a message for all of us
that people can pull themselves
out of all kinds of situations,
given an opportunity.
So this idea of giving
loans and building up
this kind of financing
institution caught up
globally, and in many
countries is being used.
This also led us to think
about other things, information
technology for example.
We thought not only
microcredit is important,
microfinance is important.
Information technology is also
important for poor people.
We got an opportunity, and
skipping the whole story,
we created a mobile phone
company called Grameen Phone.
Everybody-- that's a crazy idea.
You are lending
money to poor people.
Why do you want a
cell phone company?
We said, we want
to bring cell phone
in the villages of
Bangladesh, and give loans
to the poor women so that she
can buy herself a cell phone
and start selling the service
of a cell phone in the village
and make money.
Who is going to use the
cell phone in the village?
I said, whoever wants to
make a call to anybody.
Everyone thought, this,
it will never work.
But it became a
rolling business.
Women took loans, started
selling service in the village.
And many villages in
Bangladesh have no electricity.
70% of the population
of Bangladesh
do not have access
to electricity.
So how do you bring cell
phones in the village
where there is no electricity?
And most of the villages
don't have electricity.
We promptly came
up with an idea.
Solar panel, that's it.
So we started plugging
into solar panels.
So now everywhere
[? it helps, ?] mobile phones.
There are 170,000
telephone ladies
in Bangladesh selling service
of telephone who never
saw telephone in their
life, never heard that there
is a gadget called telephone.
People used to tell
us, well, you're
giving money to
the women, OK, all
she can do all her life is
to raise chicken, or make
basket, or raise a cow.
Because she cannot come out
of the traditional technology,
ever.
So when we wanted
to give telephones,
they said, no way,
she will be scared.
And I was always arguing
that don't underestimate
the talent of human beings.
They are very creative people.
There is no difference between
the poor women and anybody
else.
So that is only
something in an idea.
But it's wonderful
to see that people
reacted exactly the same way.
Now today you go and talk to any
telephone lady in Bangladesh,
you can make a call from here.
[AUDIENCE CHUCKLING]
They talk in the
business language.
She talks as if she was born
with a telephone in her hand.
She knows everything, ins
and outs of a telephone.
What a confident person she is.
People ask me, what is this
that you see as poverty?
How do you define poverty?
I said, I don't know
how to define poverty.
But to me it's something that
I see as a kind of image which
comes close to my mind.
It's a bonsai tree.
That bonsai, little tree, I say
poor people are bonsai people.
You choose the tallest
tree in the forest.
It's a beautiful tall
And pick up the best
seed for that tree.
And plant it in a flower pot.
What do you get?
Tiny little tree.
It doesn't grow very much.
It looks exactly like the
tree you saw in the forest.
It's a small replica
of that tree.
Is there something wrong
with the seed of the tree?
No, we picked the best seed.
Then why is it so small?
Because we plant it
in a small flower pot.
We didn't give the tree
space enough to grow.
So it's not the fault of the
seed, it's the space denied.
Poor people are
just like that tree.
They're as good human
being as anybody else.
Simply they are not
given the space.
So the poverty is not
created by them, it's
created by the institutions
we built. Banking institution
is one.
Policies that we pursued,
even the concepts
that we design and we
discuss in our classrooms,
ultimately impacts on the
society that we create.
So if you want to get the
poverty out of the world,
you have to redesign
those concepts,
redesign those
theoretical structures.
If you fix those things,
nobody will be poor person.
Because their ability to
take care of themselves
is inside of them.
All human beings have
unlimited potentials.
Most of us in the world
scratch only the surface,
and the poor people never
even scratch the surface.
So the gift each human
being has inside of them,
among the poor people, that
give remains unwrapped.
It's been packed.
It never gets opened.
So when we talk about
microcredit or all those things
that I'm talking about,
this gives an opportunity
to make a little bit of
openings, find out who I am.
And that's the one--
that's the important thing,
to see what is inside of me
and how much of it
I can bring out.
And if you can
allow that, if you
can create that kind
of society, there's
no reason why anybody
should languish
in that misery and suffering.
And one way to do it--
I'll quickly stop at that--
is to redesign the
concept of business.
The business today is understood
everywhere, in our textbooks,
in our theory, in
our real world.
Business mean business
to make money.
I said, interpretation of
human beings in that way
is a very limited way.
Human beings are much more--
it has much more variety
inside of a human being
than just that.
Human beings cross
the whole range
of feelings, whole range of
dimensions inside of them.
So I said, if we could
include, in a idea of business,
as two kinds of business.
Business to make
money is one, business
to do good to other
people is another one.
We can run business
to do good to people.
These would be
businesses which are not
concerned to make profit,
but to reach out to people,
solve social problems
in a business way.
These are non-loss companies.
It doesn't lose money.
It's a break-even company.
Could be done.
And we can address most of the
social problems in a business
way.
If we can put them in a
business way, social business,
this we can call
social business--
if we can make social business
enterprises, a lot of problems
can be addressed that way.
Problem of poverty-- like
microcredit, for example,
can be addressed that way--
problem of children
suffering, child labor,
livelihood creation, crimes,
drinking water, sanitation,
health care, and social
business enterprises.
We need social
business entrepreneurs.
People say ah ha,
I want to do this.
This is a challenge
I want to take.
I can design things and
I can run a business,
not for me to make money,
but to reach out and solve
the problem.
So this is a challenge.
This is an idea
what I think time
has come to address
lots of problems
that we see around ourselves.
And thank you very much.
I'll stop here.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE CONTINUES]
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
MODERATOR: We don't
have much time.
Unfortunately Dr. Yunus has
to head back to New York.
It's a busy week for him.
So we have microphones
somewhere here.
Yes, here and there.
And so if you would
please come up.
And I'm sorry, it's
the only way we're
going to be able to hear you.
And if you'll just line up, and
we'll try to get as many of you
in.
Be as brief and
concise as possible.
Thank you.
Please go ahead.
AUDIENCE: It's a
very inspiring thing
you do for all those people.
I had a practical
question, which
is how specifically do you guys
actually run the operation?
How do you collect, how do you
determine how much interest you
charge and how much interest
people get in their deposits?
YUNUS: I will have a one
full-blown lecture for that.
We have branches.
We have over 1,600 branches
in the country in Bangladesh.
Each staff is responsible for
a certain number of borrowers,
to take care of their
needs and so on.
All Grameen Bank
activities are organized
around building
five-member groups.
Five people form a kind
of a business circle.
And several of those
groups together
create what we call a center.
The center meets each week where
the business is transacted.
Our basic principle is people
should not come to the bank,
the bank should
go to the people.
So we always go to the people.
Every week, we meet all
our five million borrowers
at their doorstep, and do the
business at their doorstep.
And all our loans are paid
back in weekly installments.
So this is basically
the operational details.
AUDIENCE: And what's
the average interest
rate you charge people?
YUNUS: Interest rate,
we try to be as close as
possible to the
market interest rate.
Market interest rate today
in Bangladesh is about 14%.
We have four interest
rates in our work.
One is 20%, which is 6%
above the market rate.
And the next one is
the housing loan.
Housing loan is 8%, which is
way below the market rate.
And next one is 5% for the
student loan, which is again
way below the market rate.
And for beggars, it's 0%.
So together we are
close to market rate.
And we also a deposit collector.
So on our deposits,
we pay 8 and 1/2%
interest on deposits, minimum.
And it goes all the way to 12%.
So we pay 8 and 1/2% to 12%, and
we charge 20%, 8%, 5%, and 0%.
That's it.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
YUNUS: Thank you.
MODERATOR: Please.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
Thank you, Dr. Yunus, for your
comments and for all your work.
My name is Raven.
I'm from the Fletcher School.
And with all the
kind of enthusiasm
surrounding
microfinance right now,
I've heard it said
as a word of caution
that microcredit especially,
offered first to the poor,
can really cause harm to
those who are in need of it.
And I'm curious, just as
your comments and advice
to those enthusiastic
about microfinance, what
are you doing and
what do you recommend
should be done in the way of
offering other interventions
to ensure that this
capital provided to them
doesn't in fact indebt them.
Thank you.
YUNUS: Yeah.
One thing to be careful when
you give loans to people,
we try to make sure
that this money is used
for income-generating purposes.
Money should create money.
Once you consume it
up, take the money,
and then you create yourself
the obligations, and the debt
burden, and all kinds of things.
So that's why we created all
of those groups and so on.
You can mutually oversee
each other's activities
so that you don't use the
money in the wrong way.
Because we give loans for
income-generating activity.
So you have to
demonstrate, you have
to explain to your
own group members
what you are going
to do with the money,
how this money will
bring money for you.
Bank doesn't approve the loan.
Basic approval is done
by her own friends.
So she has to explain
everything what
she is going to do so that
they can go and check it out.
So this is one way we see to
protect them from using up
the money in the wrong way.
AUDIENCE: Are there
any other activities
such as capacity-building,
or market value chain
improvements, or
productivity-enhancement
activities that the bank
does along with the lending?
YUNUS: We don't have any
program of training as such,
but we try to connect
them with each other.
If you are doing something,
and somebody else
is doing the similar
thing in the next center,
we say, ah, she
is doing this, why
don't you get together
and see what do you do.
They learn from each
other much faster.
And one thing comes because
of some kind of jealousy
that she is doing so good
and I'm not doing it.
So she would like
to be equal to her.
So this is also good.
This is a creative jealousy that
she tries to get even with her
and prove that she can
perform better than her.
It's a neighborly jealousy.
That works pretty well.
And we encourage-- we always
give examples of what others
are doing, so that she feels--
[AUDIENCE CHUCKLING]
She feels, ah ha,
how can she do that?
But thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
YUNUS: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MODERATOR: Please,
one question each.
No follow-up.
I'm sorry-- just to
allow everyone a chance.
AUDIENCE: Hey, Dr. Yunus,
Juan Garcia from ICIC.
Thank you for coming
and speaking to us.
I read your book, felt very
empowered, [INAUDIBLE]..
My question is, in your
book, you touch a little
bit about the example of
microcredit financing here
in the US.
And it seems it was not as
successful as we had expected.
So in the wake of Katrina,
and with all the people
left behind with nothing,
how can an example like yours
become relevant?
YUNUS: Very much.
I just wrote an op ed--
I don't know if anybody
published it yet--
mentioning that.
Because Bangladesh has
lots of experience of going
through floods and disaster.
This is our normal life.
We face this all the time.
So we had to learn
this over time.
One of the things we find
very useful in a situation
of disaster-- microcredit-- to
build it back again quickly,
because of all the
mechanism is set
to get you started all over
again, put you on your feet.
Here, [INAUDIBLE]
this would been
an occasion in New Orleans.
Tried two things-- one is
microcredit, crediting channels
so that people can go
back and start their life
all over again,
build their houses,
build their
livelihood and so on.
Another one, this is
a good opportunity
also for building up social
business enterprises,
social entrepreneurs coming--
social business entrepreneurs
coming and designing
things in a business way
to address these issues.
Money going as a
handout, as a giveaway
sometimes don't achieve the
purpose for which you do.
But if you are doing it
in a business format,
it works much faster
and much efficiently.
So this is one occasion I would
think would help enormously.
MODERATOR: Please.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
Many of us are familiar with
the arsenic in the drinking
water in Bangladesh.
And I'm wondering if
you have taken any steps
to apply your philosophy
to empowerment of women
in providing safe
drinking water.
YUNUS: Yeah.
We try all the time.
This is a terrible thing that
we have been going through.
Grameen Bank has encouraged
people to have tube wells.
We gave loans to
have tube wells.
At that time, we had
no idea that this
is going to lead to
another kind of problem.
UNICEF was so enthusiastic
about tube wells.
We thought, we should have tube
well for every single family
in Grameen Bank, which we
generously kind of promoted.
So now we feel
guilty that this is
being the source of such
a terrible thing, arsenic.
So quickly, what we did,
like others have done,
kind of classify
those tube wells which
are-- arsenic content
is so high that it's not
usable for drinking purposes.
Which, others are still usable
because arsenic problem doesn't
exist.
Once we have done that, then
we have, on a second level,
where the arsenic exists,
how to clean it up.
So there are
certain methods now.
[? As a ?] pitcher--
three-pitcher system
which we encourage.
And then encouraging them to
go into rainwater harvesting.
People are not
familiar in rainwater
[? harvesting. ?] Bangladesh
is a country of rains.
In monsoon, we get
enormous amount of rain.
But people don't drink
rainwater because there's water
everywhere.
So now we're encouraging them
to build rainwater harvesting
system and purify
the surface water.
But it's still the real
answer has not come.
Arsenic is still
a major problem.
We are still working on it.
AUDIENCE: But you are
providing loans for that.
YUNUS: Pardon?
Yes, we provide loans.
Loans, that's no problem.
AUDIENCE: But that is not--
YUNUS: It's the technology
that's the problem right now
for us.
AUDIENCE: But that is not
generating income, is it?
YUNUS: No.
We give housing loan.
It's the same old thing.
We have given housing loan.
We have gone to debate.
Everybody said, you
don't give housing loan
because it doesn't
generate income.
We said, no, it
generates income.
It's a very productive loan.
If you can sleep peacefully,
that's very good.
This gives you the
energy to do that.
And for women-- because
our borrowers are women--
the house is also our factory.
That's where she works.
So if you cannot--
if you leave this roof
open, she can't work.
So it's very important.
So what is productive,
what is non-productive
is something that
you have to decide
in the context of the situation.
So simply say, drinking
water is not productive,
it's wouldn't be a
good thing to say.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MODERATOR: Thank you.
Please.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
What kind of results
have you find
in impact evaluation related
with poverty alleviation
with the loans compared
with groups that
haven't received the loans?
YUNUS: Yeah.
There are lots of studies
done on Grameen Bank,
on many, many different issues.
Grameen Bank became a very
attractive research subject
for many reasons--
for women, for credit,
for poverty alleviation,
for health, and so on.
So in all this, they have
uniformly came to the finding
that people in Grameen
Bank have moved out
of poverty consistently.
One World Bank study gives
a very specific number.
They said, 5% of the
Grameen borrowers
come out of poverty every year.
And we have been
trying to make sure
not only 5%, that
speed, can we make it
faster so that larger and larger
percentage of Grameen borrowers
get out of poverty each year,
and each month, each day,
each week.
Because people don't wait
until the end of the year
to get out of poverty.
[AUDIENCE CHUCKLING]
They get out every day--
one family today,
next family tomorrow,
depending on where you are.
So we want to see
that happening.
Another study shows that
getting out of poverty
starts as soon as about
five cycles of loans.
But there may be families
which takes 15 cycles of loans
still in poverty.
So we are trying to see how to
reduce that 15 cycles to come
down to 10 cycle,
and fifth cycle
to come to the fourth cycle,
so that the range in between
becomes shorter and shorter,
people, all kinds of people
come.
And we see the reason it's
prolonged for many families is
sickness, disease.
So the health became
another worry for us.
We still can address
that health issue.
And that's, we
see, the challenge
for anybody who is interested
in poverty alleviation,
how to address the
health care services
to come to the poorest
people in an affordable way
so that they can get out
of the health problems
that they suffer.
Poor also means poor in health.
It goes together.
So now you have to
address it simultaneously.
We are addressing one
part, but we still
couldn't get to the health part.
So this is where we are now
trying to say, can we build,
in a Grameen-type health
care in a virtual way
within Bangladesh, to
build it up in a way
that nobody is left out
of health care system.
MODERATOR: We're going to have
time for a couple of questions.
I'm very sorry.
Please, so we'll just
go as far as we can.
We have five minutes.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Mr. Yunus, thank you
for your inspiring talk.
YUNUS: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: When you
told your story,
I couldn't help but think
that the banker you approached
might feel like IBM does
after meeting with Bill Gates.
[CHUCKLING]
I have two quick questions.
You can answer
whichever you like.
You said--
YUNUS: You give me options.
AUDIENCE: Yes, options are good.
Now, you said you had an
original set of rules when
you made the first small leap.
If you could go into
detail about those
rules that you had for the
first 42 of your borrowers.
And two, do you have
any advice for people
who are thinking of
replicating a similar scheme
for microinsurance?
Because given the
disasters that take place,
people often lose
their livelihoods.
And we've had discussions--
students-- about microinsurance.
Thank you.
YUNUS: Yes, microinsurance
is a very important thing.
Let me take the
microinsurance part of it.
We have been providing
health insurance.
We have developed a health care
system, but in a limited area.
We are trying it out.
I'll explain a little bit more.
Each Grameen Bank
family in that area
where we have the micro health--
insurance can join the insurance
program by paying about $3.00
a year.
If you put $3.00 a year, entire
family comes under the health
care insurance.
And for that, you have a
fully-qualified doctors
in the area, and the
paramedics, and health workers,
and you can buy medicine
at 25% discount,
and you have pathological
lab right there, and so on.
So today, in the 20 areas that
we work, we cover about 90%
of our cost in expenses
that we have to incur.
So still have a 10% gap.
So we are trying to see if we
can come to the 10% recovery
so that we can expand it
globally, all over Bangladesh.
Because we cannot expand
it globally if you have
to subsidize it from the
resources that we have.
So this is where we
are looking for-- this
is the health insurance part.
Then we have the loan insurance.
Loan insurance is simply
if a borrower dies
and she lives behind--
of course she leaves
behind the loan amount.
Under this insurance,
entire loan amount
is paid off by the
insurance, so the family
doesn't have to worry about it.
And not only it's a financial
relief for the family,
it's also a great satisfaction
for the borrower herself
when she is alive.
Because she feels,
when she dies,
she can go very clean to God.
She has not left behind
any loan obligation.
Because this is a part of
their religious feeling
that if she leaves
behind a loan,
God will be extremely
unhappy with her.
Until somebody takes care of
that loan, she has to suffer.
So now she feels very
happy that the insurance
takes care of everything.
She feels that I have not been
creating any burden on anybody
in my life.
When I am dead, I don't
want to leave any burden
on anybody else.
I can go clean.
So that's loan insurance.
Another one is life insurance.
We also have life
insurance coverage.
So this is loan
insurance, life insurance
is universal within
Grameen Bank.
It's already there.
But the health insurance is
for just a limited experiment
we are doing.
We hope we will be
successful in that.
Thank you.
MODERATOR: Thank you.
I think that's all
the time we have.
I'm very sorry.
Please.
HOCKFIELD: Well, this has been
an extraordinary afternoon.
And I want to remind you all
that none of these things
happen by virtue of
a single individual.
And we owe an enormous amount
of thanks to our alumnus
Mohammed Jameel from
the class of 1978
for making it possible for
Dr. Yunus to be with us today.
MIT, we pride
ourselves by saying
we're the kind of people
who solve problems.
And I cannot tell you how
inspiring it is to see how one
individual, through
intelligence, initiative,
persistence, has made an
enormous inroad in one
of the world's
greatest problems,
which is global poverty.
I want you to please join with
me in taking Dr. Yunus once
again for an inspiring talk.
[APPLAUSE]